[Music]
so we have all sorts of biases to favor
our own group over others some of these
biases I think are morally respectable
I'm not embarrassed that I love my
children more than I love other children
I love my wife more than I love other
people but others are less respectable
we have biases about skin color about
national origin about even sports teams
where these things may seem kind of
arbitrary and not very important but you
play a huge role in our life where are
usually biased creatures we're naturally
carved the world into in-group and
out-group I do some research on babies
and I would argue that this in-group
out-group distinction comes naturally
just that you could see it in babies
before their first birthday um even if
empathy were to be stripped from our
heads if you were to take a pill that
would blot out your empathy you still be
biased you still favor yours over the
other group there are many sources of
bias they seem to be wired into all of
our emotions all of our decision-making
but empathy is particularly vulnerable
to bias I use the analogy of it as a
spotlight and in fact many of the fans
of empathy use it that analogy as well
because it captures the apparent good at
empathy could do it zooms you in and
makes you care but a spotlight only
illuminates a small area and a spotlight
only illuminates where you point it and
so empathy is exquisitely subject to
bias because our bias tells us where the
spotlight is pointed to I could try to
do a rational cost-benefit analysis and
I could do a pretty good shot at being
unbiased and fair adding up the people
who suffer from the people who benefit
figuring out a solution but once empathy
comes into the mix bias is inevitable
and so empathy making decisions based on
empathy exaggerated SAR in-group
out-group bias it brings it to the fore
and makes it very hard to override so
it's it's a great question what goes on
when we're so rotten to other people and
one ingredient of it I think really is
dehumanization it's when we think of the
out-group
not as a peep
but just as things and this doesn't
necessarily motivate cruelty you're not
cruel to things you're not cruel to
nonhumans but it but it motivates a sort
of moral indifference and so if you want
to ignore the fates of people
dehumanizing them is a great way to do
so I'm somewhat skeptical though about
the importance of dehumanization in in
in atrocities I used to be I used to
think this played a huge role I was
convinced by people who do wonderful
work like David Livingstone Smith who
argue dehumanization that the core of
all evils but now I'm less certain
there's been critiques of this work and
a lot of critiques point out that the
people we hate the most the people we
torment the most caused them to suffer
the most aren't people we don't view as
people because if you don't if you miss
people why would you want to make them
suffer it's people you hate it's people
in other words it's not people you kind
of dehumanize but it's rather people who
you acknowledge their humanity and this
is why you want to make them suffer this
is court wanting to make them suffer I
was on the radio earlier today and
before me there was a segment on revenge
porn and it was chilling it was it was
typically men in relationships and
relationships go bad and then they go on
to post you know intimate photos and
videos of their girlfriend on porn sites
send them to their family members
registered refer to sexual offender
sites and STD sites put on their address
and contact information online to try to
go to other men and to sexually
assaulting them and you think about what
happens what behaviors evil as that and
it's not that these men are thinking oh
their girlfriends are nothing they're
not even human
it's rather they are they think their
girlfriends have committed is horrible
moral wrong and they want them to suffer
so I think that in some ways sadism and
cruelty of all sorts involves a
recognized
the humanity of the other person because
this recognition is what fuels the the
cruelty if you thought that they weren't
human you may want to eradicate them
gonna get rid of them but you wouldn't
want them to suffer so much
[Music]